-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-winning actor
you know from films such as
"Mystic River",
"Milk", and
"Fast Times at Ridgemont High".
He's the director and star of
"Flag Day",
which is in theaters everywhere
now.
Please welcome to the show
Sean Penn.
♪♪
Thank you so much
for being here, my friend.
♪♪
Thank you so much
for being here in person.
-Thanks for having me.
-This is based on a book
by Jennifer Vogel
about her father,
called "Flim-Flam Man",
and it as it crossed your path
years ago.
-Yeah, I read it, oh,
almost 15 years ago,
I think,
and it had a long journey
getting to the point
of making it,
and now we've finally
gotten the chance to do that.
-And this is --
like I mentioned,
this is about her relationship
with her father,
and you in turn, then decided to
cast your daughter...
-Mm-hmmm.
-...to play Jennifer.
Is that something that
occurred to you right away,
as well,
when you were reading it?
-Yeah, in a very unique way.
With this script,
it -- I was at about page 30
and her face
just got imprinted on it
and I couldn't get it
out of my head.
And then it was a question
of waiting
until she was ready to do it.
She didn't want to do it.
She didn't --
She just thought that acting was
the silliest thing in the world
as a profession, as a teenager.
And as she came
to embrace it more,
I think, principally, as
an avenue to be a director,
which is what she wants to do.
She came into it
and is just extraordinary
in the movie.
-She's really wonderful,
and, you know, she plays someone
who is very vulnerable
because of the way
her father is.
And I imagine, one --
first of all,
acting's very vulnerable
to begin with,
but then as your --
if you're a parent,
you must always feel like your
children seem vulnerable to you.
How -- Was it even harder
to direct her
because she was your daughter,
especially in those
tricky father/daughter scenes?
Or was it just natural
because that is the relationship
you guys have?
-I think that there was a real
shorthand that you gain
from being close for 30 years.
And so, somebody calls it
blood harmony,
then -- there's -- when
it happens, it can be magic.
And watching her, she had always
been so uncontrived as a person.
And to see her as an actress
be so uncontrived
and to be able to watch
her think without being told
what she's thinking by her
is a very moving thing.
So I think that
it was probably helpful.
-Your son, Hopper,
in the film as well.
-Yeah.
-Is this just a father
using jobs in movies to spend
more time with your kids?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And did it work? Was it good?
Was it good
family time together?
-It was great.
I don't sleep very well,
but when my kids
are under the same roof
or in some proximity,
I suddenly sleep.
So I was able to sleep
on this shoot in ways
I hadn't been before.
Yeah, it was --
And then I've just been -- kind
of took the show on the road
with Dylan, you know,
doing press for the movie.
And so she still gets
ball and chained to me.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a good plan.
-Did you have -- What was
Jennifer Vogel's relationship
with the project?
Did you talk to her a lot?
I mean, obviously, this is
so intensely personal to her.
-Yeah. I mean, we just lucked
out that Jennifer Vogel
happens to be the most
extraordinarily supportive,
even of poetic license.
You know, she gets it.
She gets film.
So she was really
a collaborator.
And there were times where
we were making revisions --
we'd always bounce it by her.
She came to set a few times.
You know, her book is the movie
and then some,
because we I just tried to
express
the center core
of the story with the movie.
But she has -- I mean, the book,
"Flim-Flam Man"
is an extraordinarily
well-written book.
-After this really
difficult 18 months,
some movies are lucky enough
to be in theaters again.
I know you appreciate
watching a movie in theaters.
Is it extra special that this is
a film that can be consumed
that way as well as at home?
-Yeah, for me, the fact that
it's in the theaters
and particularly that
it's exclusively
in the theaters, because I think
that baits those like me.
You know, if I'm interested
in seeing a film,
I don't want the convenience
of the small box
when something was,
as "Flag Day" was,
made for the big screen.
And so I was very fortunate,
you know, in this day and age
that I have an MGM distributor
who believed in it that way
and gave us
this exclusive period.
Of course,
it will eventually stream.
But I do always feel,
at this point in time,
that I have to say that
I hope -- I'd ask
that as as much as I want people
all to go to the theater,
I really only want people
who are vaccinated and safe
to themselves
and each other to go.
And it will stream,
but most of the people
who aren't vaccinated
probably aren't interested
in my movies anymore.
-Yeah, that's a good point.
[ Laughs ]
Did you -- Do you like watching
yourself on a big screen
or do you have
the anxiety of somebody
just watching themselves
perform?
-I am not my own aesthetic.
-OK, got you.
-You know, as a director --
It's why I've never
cast myself before.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, that's true.
So you've directed
multiple films.
This is the first time you're
directing yourself as an actor.
Yeah.
Were you difficult?
Did you find yourself
hard to work with?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, no,
I...
I found one thing really made --
a surprising thing,
because, you know,
it's a lot more work
and it's already a 17 1/2 hour
a day job to direct a movie.
But I didn't have to --
you know, with the principal
two actors,
which is led by Dylan,
but me,
I didn't have to negotiate
the ego politics
that you do.
You know, you've given an actor
10 takes on this side
and you come around
on the other, you give him two
and they say,
"What's this about?"
And it would have been four,
because you would have done
an extra two takes
to make them feel good,
but your focus is on Jennifer,
who's the lead in the story,
and you really want to put
your time in there.
So, it was easy.
That was one thing that offered
a little less fatigue.
-That's nice.
I want to come back, ask more,
and we're going to show
a clip as well.
Be right back with more
from Sean Penn.